back here in the united states the
murder suspect whose escape led to a
nationwide manhunt is back in the
alabama jail that he escaped from casey
white was extradited from indiana last
night following his capture there on
monday an indiana coroner says his
alleged accomplice corrections official
vicki white no relation died by suicide
following a self-inflicted gunshot wound
to the head police have released footage
of the fugitives final moments on the
run
omar villafranca has more on the story
and a warning here some of the images
you're about to see
are graphic
this dash cam video from police in
evansville indiana shows escaped inmate
casey white as he's dragged from the
wreckage of his getaway vehicle white
who faces capital murder charges is
eventually walked over to the hood of
the police car in handcuffs
moments later officers pulled former
alabama corrections officer vicki white
from the overturned car as well as the
firearm they believe she used to shoot
herself
members of the u.s task force basically
rammed the vehicle and pushed it into a
ditch
and we later found out had they not done
that
the fugitive was going to engage in a
shootout with law enforcement
authorities later recovered four loaded
handguns a loaded ar-15 style rifle and
ammunition from his car in addition to
camping gear and roughly 29 000 in cash
the fugitives arrest came a week and a
half after they were first reported
missing
and five days after evansville police
first inspected their previous getaway
car which had been abandoned at a local
car wash it was that tip one of close to
600 the u.s marshals service as it
received that helped steer authorities
to the whites hideout at this motel and
ultimately the chase that ended in their
capture
for cbs mornings i'm omar villafranca